débit cumulé ces bâtisses il y a cinq
ans emmurées dans son monde le fils de
laurence nadeau à 9 ans aujourd'hui il
ne parle toujours pas et fréquente une
école spécialisée pour les jeunes
autistes
si elle a des services maintenant madame
nadeau s'inquiète pour l'avenir et ceux
qui seront adultes dans quelques années
qu'ils sont déjà ou va-t-on les maîtres
on peut pas juste les garder chez soi
jusqu'à notre mort devant le bureau de
la ministre lucie charlebois à montréal
des parents en attente de services se
sont joints et mon père de charlotte qui
n'a pas accès à leur tofo nice le plan
d'action présenté en mars dernier n'ont
aucun impact pour eux c'est qu'on peut
pas couper des services de certains pour
en offrir à dos c'est pas du
développement de servais ça il ya très
très peu d'avancé et il ya certaines
régions de hockey vous êtes ont
privilégié mais c'est pas partout pareil
la ministre charlebois reconnaît qu'il y
à beaucoup à faire une chose ce qu'on
donne beaucoup plus de services qu'on en
donne est johan et on voit ça milliards
en france un plan d'action sur 5 1 pour
l'instant c'est trop peu pour les
parents et les organismes communautaires
qui constate même des pertes de service
pour certains groupes d'âge selon ce qu
elle seule sait où ça en est où
parce qu'on va pas plus de services on
voit pas plus de accès au service
on va encore des listes atteint le 29
millions merci beaucoup mais c'est loin
d'être capable de répondre aux besoins
de toute la population des personnes
autistes y les besoins augmentent en
flèche le nombre de personnes
diagnostiquées avec un trouble du
spectre de l'autisme double tous les
quatre ans ici and with despatie radio
canada montréal